qui me choque hier quand on en parlait
on a justement essayé d'éviter cet
écueil parce que c'est un écueil trouver
à un moment des raisons alors qu'on est
dans l'émotion c'est très compliqué
maintenant admettons on va faire comme
si les Israéliens l'avaient bien mérité
hein l'avit bien mérité exactement ce
que tu dis quelle honte mais c'est ce
que tu viens de H est-ce qu' a des gens
on lucidité autour de ce PL que tu dis
depuis tout à l'heure c'est que tu 75
ans il il faut un moment Karim assume ce
que tu
dis
h moi je vous dis que c'est
honte hteain
de dire pourquoi tu as dit qu'il Ava des
causes tu as dit qu'il y avait des
causes écoute et regarde-moi bien dans
les yeux parce que je va poser une
question et elle est claire si on estime
que la politique israélienne on va dire
est responsable de ce qui s'est passé
moi je vais te dire un truc qu'a mérité
la France pour avoir connu le batlan
vas-y mais quel est le rapport entre VO
le combat le combat voilà l'aspiration
d'un peuple qui serit peutêtre tu peux
juste me répondre mais je te demande
parce que si on explique un truc en
disant il faut pas oublier la cause et
le combat c'est ça qui a créé l'attentat
explique-moi quelle est la cause qui a
provoqué le bat àlan j'aimerais juste
entendre là-dessus parce que regarde-moi
dans les yeux s'il te plaît je te
regarde je te dis avec une gentilless
TER avec ton cinéma regarde-moi dans les
yeux là pas du tout prend pour tu es en
train de de penser que je fu le regard
là mais r répond-moi simplement de la
fermer quand je
parle
je je su de
pas de la
vieurais m'ter
trard réponds juste à ma question s'il
te plaît tu je t dis si Israël donc a
provoqué quelque part à cause de sa
politique cet attentat explique-moi ce
que la France a fait pour mériter le
batlan c'est extrêmement simple pas
simple comme réponse comme question
maintenant la réponse va être compliqué
parce que là tu te rends compes que dans
ta dialctique tu sur le même niveauiss
ré PL laiss ré répondre laiss répondre
s'il vous plaît merci fait je trouve que
tu intellectuellement malhonnête ou
parce que tu fais un lien s'il vous
plaît entre de drame lien qui n'a pas
lieu d'être le Bataclan est un drame
absolu dialetique pas Dr ditique qui a
porté atinte au cœur de tous les
Français que nous sommes et dans le
Bataclan il y avait des gens de toute
origine de toute confession ils ont
frappé avec une
idéologie comme en Israël en Israël en
Israël il y a une problématique qui est
celle d'un peuple qu'il faut dissocier
du hamass enfin et d'un peuple que la
politique israélienne tue à petit feu
depuis 56 ans avec aucune espérance
possible d'avoir un état et toute une
génération qui grandit dans cet état
d'esprit et donc une démocratie
politique qui s'appelle Israël avec un
gouvernement que je diss AE des
Israéliens et encore plus des juif parce
que moi je ne fais jamais la confusion
et j'espère qu'avant la fin on va quand
même dire un mot sur le le scandale
c'était le troisème que je voulais
traiter mais avec beaucoup de
difficultés c'est de ne pas importer le
conflit sur notre sol parce que je pense
effectivement que ce serait dramatique
je ne comprends pas que tu le lien entre
le
B qu' veut te dire fait
que terrorisme DRAM d'accord et et avec
lequel on doit faire
li te c'est du terrorisme dans les estce
que j'ai nié que çaétait
pour j'aié c'est ce qu'il veut dire il
veut dire quoi je ve dire quelque chose
de simple au lieu de parler des causes
parle uniquement déjà du fait et essae
au moins de montrer aux gens que la
première chose à dire c'est de dire on
est tous contre le terrorisme si tu
essayes de trouver des causes tu vas
justifier la preuve plein de gens ont
compris ici que tu justifia cet acte
donc je te
on va faire un autre exemple on prend le
batlan qu'est-ce qui peut justifier
l'injustifiable rien rien peut justifier
le batlan rien justifie ce qui s'est
passé samedi désolé Karim mais tu bien
que ton
discoursour
discoursme pas qu les G écouter ce que
tu as dit à
Radio cette
malhonné direct c'est en direct g
dis
am ni ni terroriste tu parles de rien
radio ALG je vous encourage à l'écouter
si un
propos question à lu
poserère est-ce une responsabilité
politique de l'État d'Israël à la
situation aujourd'hui du peuple
palestinien qui n'a pas d'état je te
rappelle je te pose une question je vais
te répondre moi tu m'as déjà V
tergiverser tu fais ça allez-y répondez
qui gère la bande de Gaza depuis 2005
question le Gaza à gaz pardon à Gaza qui
est parti d'ailleurs de façon
unilatérale du jour au lendemain àon en
disant maintenant vous gérez ça donc
responsabilité la différence entre toi
et moi c'est que moi je suis rien je
suis écoute
bien automatiquement une responsabilité
politique on l'a dit hier je le dis tout
le temps pourquoi est que le Hamas est
une création de nan tu rends compte que
jeux je te des israli qui disent des
diplomates pas h je ne relais que la
parole de ceux qui de l'Intérieur ont
expliqué sa stratégie est-ce que c'est
une stratégie à laquelle tu crois ou pas
écoute non seulement j'ai honte pour toi
mais je te
direpond ça correspond à un chef du
ramas hier qui expliquait qu'il y avait
pas de victime civil et que donc
évidemment que quand il découpa en
morceau et qu'il tuait des habitants il
est considéré comme des com
combatist Ren voir dans la situation
écoute-moi mais tu n'écoutes pas tu fais
si on faisait un décompte comme aux
échecs tu serais à non c'est très
bienous les jours et toi tu n pas tu pas
alors moi j suis tous les jours
laissemo ce so pe par T les jours on le
critique du matin au soir on n pas
besoin de personne pour critiquer la
politique israélienne elle est critiqu
en Israël plus que n'importe où ailleurs
parce que moins il connaiss ce pays
deuxè c'est important la responsabilité
d'Israël elle est bien dans un sens et
dans l'utre parce que ils managent leur
relation depuis des années avec non
seulement la bande de Gaza administré
par le Hamas entité terroriste élu quand
même à 77 % tu te rappelles puisquon en
avait parlé par les Gazaoui et de
l'autre côté une pseudo Autorité
palestinienne qui est au pouvoir depuis
plus de 18 qui
refuseie ce qui justifie Fran tapir
centes de
résolution des dizaines de traités
refusé par les palestinens son une
dernière
question
écoute répond des centaines de
résolutions de l'ONU non respect que je
peuxler est-ce que je peux parler tu as
dit que le tu as dit que leam avait été
créé par Israël et par Natan est-ce que
tu res n c'est pas pareil r la bêtise
mon Dieu s'il vous plaît si on pouvait
effacer ça de vos mémoires il faudit le
faire tu seras ridicule à vie en disant
un truc
pareil décapitations
comm Contin parler tous les de
mer c'est
unecnaissance merci tout la vérité qui
compte merci